wenn sie Benito Mussolini zuhören der
ein oder zwei Dinge über Faschismus
wusste er sagte der Faschismus sei die
Verschmelzung von staatlicher und
unternehmerischer macht jetzt werden die
Leute das bestreiten und sagen dass das
nicht genau das ist was er gesagt hat
aber wenn man sich wirklich damit
beschäftigt ist es das
Milch ist ein wichtiger Bestandteil
jeder guten Ernährung verwenden Sie die
beste Milchqualität die ihnen zur
Verfügung steht durch den Genuss von
unhygienischer Rohmilch können
Krankheiten übertragen werden
[Musik]
im Jahr 2010 gab es zeitgleiche Razzien
an zwei Orten in Kalifornien
schwer bewaffnete Beamte stürmten
Privatgrundstücke und verhafteten
mehrere US-Bürger wegen des Handelns mit
einer verbotenen Substanz drogenrazien
gibt es in den USA recht häufig das ist
nur eine der Methoden mit denen die
Behörden uns von bösartigen Substanzen
fernhalten nur war dies keine
drogenabzieher
die Substanz die verkauft wurde war kein
Crack kein Crystal Meth und nicht einmal
illegaler Schnaps
es war Milch
das ist eine sehr froh das ist ein
Beispiel dafür wie rigoros die Regierung
vorgeht um missliebige Parteien
auszuschalten
in diesem Fall beruft sich die Regierung
auf das Argument des öffentlichen
Interesses das Rohmilch von Natur aus
unsicher ist sie sei ein Nährboden für
Bakterien und da sie nicht pasteurisiert
sei so dass Argument merke sie ein enorm
erhöhtes Risiko für die Verbraucher so
dass sie nicht erhältlich sein sollte
das ist der Standpunkt der
Lebensmittelbehörde FDA und die
Regierung geht gegen dieses eine Segment
mit brutaler Gewalt vor indem sie
praktisch Sturmtruppen schickt und die
gesamte Milchfabrik still legt und die
gesamte Milch beschlagnahmt unabhängig
davon ob sie kontaminiertes oder nicht
die FDA hat eine Razzia auf diesem
Biomarkt durchgeführt um uns vor den
Gefahren zu schützen die von nicht
pasteurisierter Milch ausgehen
sie haben kein Problem damit dass man
Rohmilch trinkt wenn man zum Beispiel
auf dem Heimweg eine streunende Kuh
findet und beschließt sie selbst zu
melken
aber ein seriöser Landwirt der versucht
sie an willige Kunden zu verkaufen das
geht gar nicht
obwohl es sich bei diesen Biomarkt um
einen Club handelte in dem jedes
Mitglied eine Verzichtserklärung
unterschrieben hat in der das
potenzielle Risiko des rohmilchkonsums
anerkannt wird war das für die FDA nicht
ausreichend ist diesen Leuten nicht klar
dass Rohmilch ein Einstiegs Lebensmittel
ist was kommt als nächstes Menschen die
Käse essen rohe Ostern Sushi oder Gott
bewahre Eier zum Glück war die FDA zur
Stelle und rettete diese Erwachsenen mit
vorgehaltener Waffe vor dem Gefahren der
Honig
der Grund warum pasteurisierte Milch
nicht unter diese Kontrolle fällt und
der Grund warum Rohmilch im Gegensatz zu
Käse Eiern ruhen Austern und Sushi nicht
unter dieselbe Kontrolle der FDA fällt
ist dass die großen milchhersteller eine
wichtige Lobby innerhalb der FDA sind
sie haben sehr kleine Gewinnspannen pro
Einheit und wenn in Bio merkten und
anderen Geschäften viele Verbraucher
Rohmilchprodukte kaufen hat das
erhebliche Auswirkungen auf die großen
Milchverarbeiter
die Razzien in Kalifornien waren kein
Einzelfall in den letzten Jahren gab es
überall in den usa-ratien um gegen den
Verkauf vieler Bioprodukte vorzugehen
doch trotz aller Behauptungen über
Sicherheitsbedenken oder Risiken ist
eines klar
die Maßnahmen der Aufsichtsbehörden und
damit auch der Politiker die sie leiten
sind nicht durch irgendeine Vorstellung
vom öffentlichen Wohl motiviert sie sind
motiviert durch den Wunsch an der Macht
zu bleiben und dafür braucht man Geld
das Problem des politischen Systems in
den USA ist dass sich alles um Geld
dreht und das führt sofort zu dieser
Dichotomie zwischen denen die es sich
leisten können im System mitzuspielen
und denen die es nicht können um für ein
Amt zu kandidieren braucht man
eineinhalb Millionen Dollar um für den
Senat zu kandidieren braucht man etwa 11
Millionen Dollar wenn man also kein Geld
hat wohin geht man dann man wendet sich
an die Leute die die Hand ausstrecken
und Geld bereithalten um den Wahlkampf
zu finanzieren
aber sie werden eine Gegenleistung
verlangen denn natürlich geben sie das
Geld nicht aus wohltätigen gründen
es ist ganz klar ein Vorteil für große
Unternehmen weil sie mehr Ressourcen
haben um Einfluss zu kaufen
politische Einflussnahme wird zu einem
weiteren Arsenal im
marketing-werkzeugkasten großer
Unternehmen aber anstatt sich selbst zu
fördern nutzen Sie diesen Einfluss um
die Konkurrenz zu unterdrücken und der
Schlüssel zu allem sind Lobbyisten
die Menschen glauben dass wir in einer
freien Marktgesellschaft leben aber das
stimmt nicht die Regierung und die
großen Unternehmen sind heute viel zu
eng miteinander verbunden vor allem in
den Vereinigten Staaten und das ist im
Wesentlichen auf die Lobbyarbeit
zurückzuführen
wir haben Vetternwirtschaft wir haben
keinen Kapitalismus in den USA
vor allem wenn es um das Militär geht
und die große Medizin die großen
Lebensmittelkonzerne die Monsanto und so
weiter die meisten Menschen wollen das
nicht aber trotzdem wird es uns
aufgezwungen weil man sandte durch die
Lobbyarbeit der Lebensmittelindustrie so
viel Einfluss im Kongress hat
[Musik]
was also ist Lobbying nun ganz einfach
lobbing ist die Beeinflussung von
Entscheidungen die von Gesetzgebern und
Behörden getroffen werden sie wissen
schon die Leute die die Regeln machen
und die Leute die diesen Einfluss
ausüben nennt man Lobbyisten gut
vernetzte Fachleute mit schicken Anzügen
und flotten sprechen Lobbyisten sind in
der Regel Experten in ihren Bereichen
sie beraten die Gesetzgeber wie Sie
sicherstellen können dass die Amerikaner
den größtmöglichen Nutzen aus den
Gesetzen ziehen während sie gleichzeitig
möglichen Schaden begrenzen das ist eine
gute Idee warum sollte man einen
Expertenrat nicht wollen und genau hier
wird es brenzlig manchmal beschließen
die Gesetzgeber dass der Job auf der
anderen Seite besser ist und werden
selbst Lobbyisten sie verlassen die
Regierung und gehen zu einem privaten
Unternehmen wobei sie ihre Verbindungen
und ihren Einfluss mitnehmen dieses
Phänomen wird als Drehtür bezeichnet die
Leute wechseln von der Regulierung einer
Branche zur Arbeit in derselben Branche
und manchmal auch mehrmals hin und her
Unternehmen lieben es so mächtige Leute
auf ihrer Gehaltsliste zu haben und tun
alles um sie anzulocken und die
Regulierungsbehörden helfen ihrerseits
indem sie ein paar Gesetze erlassen die
ihren künftigen Arbeitgebern zugute
kommen und mit dem Drehen der Tür kommt
eine Vielzahl neuer Gesetze die einigen
Unternehmen zugute kommen und andere
behindern aber das Geschäft läuft weiter
und am Ende wird niemand wirklich
verletzt außer natürlich den Menschen
sie werden Kongressabgeordnete sehen die
sich für ein bestimmtes Sonderinteresse
einsetzen und nach ihrem Ausscheiden für
dieses sonder Interesse arbeiten und das
gleiche gilt für alle Regierungsbehörden
in der Tat ist das die normale Art
Geschäft in Washington zu machen
Regierung uns große Unternehmen sind im
Grunde genommen dasselbe was ist der
Unterschied zwischen einem Unternehmen
und einer Regierungsbehörde wenn das
Unternehmen die Politiker mit
Wahlkampfspenden kauft und die Politiker
tun was ihnen gesagt wird indem sie
Gesetze verabschieden die das
Unternehmen verabschiedet hätte wenn das
Unternehmen die Regierung wäre
traurigerweise ist dieses Phänomen heute
nur allzu gebräuchlich und das ist nicht
spezifisch nur für eine Branche sondern
es scheint dass viele der Behörden die
die Macht haben unser tägliches Leben zu
beeinflussen durch die Drehtür
korrumpiert werden
[Musik]
wenn man Ausschüssen Regierungsbeamten
und Behörden die Macht überträgt die
Wirtschaft zu regulieren führt das immer
zu Korruption es ist zu verlockend für
die Leute diese Macht nicht für ihre
eigenen persönlichen Ziele zu nutzen und
die Drehtür ist nur ein Beweis dafür
dass es immer immer zu Korruption führt
wenn man der Regierung und ihren
Behörden die Macht gibt den Handel zu
regulieren
19 aller Bundesgesetze sind nicht das
Produkt derer die wir wählen sondern das
Produkt der nicht gewählten Leiter
dieser bürokratischen Behörden wir haben
in den USA also keine föderale Republik
die in ihren Grenzen agiert was wir
haben ist eine unbegrenzte bürokratische
Oligarchie in der diese bürokratischen
Agenturen weitgehend ohne jegliche
Rechenschaftspflicht arbeiten
das ist keine repräsentative
Regierungsform sie vertreten nur die
mächtigsten und die Leute die ihnen das
meiste Geld geben die Konzerne die
multinationalen Unternehmen haben die
Macht übernommen sei es in der
Landwirtschaft sei es im Rundfunk der
Pharmazie oder im Einzelhandel egal in
welchem Bereich einige wenige
kontrollieren alles
Gesetze und Vorschriften sind für jede
moderne Gesellschaft unerlässlich es
gibt einige Aktivitäten die zum Wohle
des Gemeinwohls kontrolliert oder
verhindert werden müssen auf welcher
Seite der Straße man fahren darf ob ein
fünfjähriger eine Flasche Jack kaufen
oder wie oft man in einer einzigen
Sitzung zum Buffet gehen darf
okay vielleicht streichen Sie jetzt den
letzten Punkt aber sie verstehen was ich
meine aber durch die vielen Absprachen
zwischen den Regulierungsbehörden und
der Industrie die sie regulieren werden
die Gesetze die unser tägliches Leben
Regeln übertrieben unnötig und oft
gerade zu unsinnig
die Sicherheit und Freiheit der Bürger
ist für einige unserer Gesetzgeber nicht
mehr das vorrangige Ziel
es gibt nur wenig was die
Bundesregierung tut das nicht von der
Entscheidung beeinflusst ist ein
bestimmtes Interesse zu bevorzugen
viele Vorschriften werden unter dem
Deckmantel des öffentlichen Interesses
erlassen aber darunter sind Sie das
Produkt von Verhandlungen zwischen
Branchenführern und der Regierung um
eine zugangsbarriere zu schaffen
und viele dieser Maßnahmen haben enorme
wirtschaftliche Folgen da sie sowohl die
Konkurrenz für ein Unternehmen
ausschalten als auch dessen
wirtschaftliche Stellung verbessern
diese Beziehung zwischen großen
Unternehmen und Regierungsbehörden wirkt
sich nicht nur auf ihre Konkurrenz in
der Wirtschaft aus sondern auch auf
unser aller tägliches Leben
in einer Volkswirtschaft möchte man die
Produkte und Dienstleistungen
produzieren die am stärksten nachgefragt
werden und niemand außer dem Markt weiß
das aber wenn Politiker auf den Plan
treten und ihr eigenes Urteilsvermögen
an die Stelle des Marktes setzen
versuchen Sie nicht einmal den Markt zu
überlisten und herauszufinden was das
Beste für uns ist sie versuchen in der
Regel nur einen bestimmten Individuum
oder einer Gruppe einen Vorteil zu
verschaffen und zwar auf Kosten einer
anderen und so gibt es klare Gewinner
und Verlierer denjenigen der eine
Subvention erhält im Gegensatz zu
demjenigen der reguliert oder besteuert
wird aber unabhängig von den
individuellen Gewinnern und Verlierern
verlieren wir alle zusammen weil
Wohlstand vernichtet wird und die
Ressourcen nicht optimal verteilt werden
genug Geld hat kann man dafür sorgen
dass man in jeder Angelegenheit die
einem am Herzen liegt gewinnt vielleicht
geht es darum die Gesetzgebung zu
stoppen vielleicht darum etwas
durchzusetzen aber letztlich geht es
darum die Politik zu gestalten und diese
Politik hat echte Auswirkungen auf unser
tägliches Leben sie bestimmt welche Art
von Produkten wir im Laden kaufen können
Sie bestimmt wie sichern diese Produkte
sind sie bestimmt was wir über diese
Produkte wissen dürfen
der Krieg der FDA gegen Rohmilch ist nur
ein Beispiel dafür wie die großen
Lebensmittelhersteller ihre Verbindungen
in Washington nutzen um unsere Auswahl
im Lebensmittelgeschäft einzuschränken
und gleichzeitig ihre eigenen Gewinne zu
steigern aber es ist beileibe nicht das
einzige Beispiel
die Regierung hat sich mit der
Landwirtschaft verbündet es gab nie
wissenschaftliche Studien die belegen
das gentechnisch veränderte Lebensmittel
mit konventionell angebauten
gleichwertig sind
die Lebensmittelbehörde der Vereinigten
Staaten sagte nun monsanto hat sich für
die Sicherheit der Lebensmittel verbirgt
und Monsanto sagte die Behörde hat
bestätigt dass sie sicher sind das ist
das Big Business und das Big government
zusammen
aber einige kleine unabhängige
Bauernhöfe entscheiden sich dafür keine
patentierten gen-
[Musik]
er betreibt seinen Hof mit einer
innovativen und radikalen Technik die er
Weidehaltung nennt das hört sich
verrückt an aber vielleicht hat er ja
recht
wir haben ganz andere Produktions- und
verarbeitungskriterien erstens bewegen
sich unsere Tiere sie sind nicht in
großen engen Tierfabriken untergebracht
unsere Tiere werden nicht mit Drogen
behandelt wir impfen nicht geben keine
Medikamente aber wir bewirtschaften
unseren Hof in einem geschlossenen
Kohlenstoffkreislauf anstatt chemischen
Dünger zu kaufen die Lokalisierung der
Kohlenstoffkreislauf die Bewegung der
Tiere das Fehlen von Medikamenten
all das ist 180 Grad anders als das
heutige industrielle globale auf Erdöl
basierende lebensmittelsystem
es gibt also einen gesunden Markt für
traditionell gezüchtetes Fleisch und
Produkte aber warum existieren nur so
wenige unabhängige Bauernhöfe im ganzen
Land
die Geschichte von Chicago und seinen
großen viehöfen symbolisiert die
wirtschaftliche Revolution die im Gange
war auf den Farmen produzierten
Maschinen und verbesserte
landwirtschaftliche Technik eine Fülle
von Lebensmitteln für das In- und
Ausland die neue Welt der
Massenproduktion erforderte eine
zunehmende Konzentration von Kapital
durch die Bündelung der Investitionen
vieler Menschen wurde die
Aktiengesellschaft zum Vorbild für die
Gründung riesiger neuer Unternehmen
durch die Globalisierung und
kooperatisierung von allem wird es für
unabhängige Landwirte für unabhängige
Menschen im lebensmittelsystem immer
schwieriger ihre Produkte an ihre
Nachbarn Freunde an die Familie oder was
auch immer zu vermarkten
und man denkt jeden Tag darüber nach
welcher Bürokrat heute in mein Leben
eindringen wird
jedes Mal wenn die Regierung in den
Markt eindringt begünstigt sie die
größten Akteure weil die in der Lage
sind sich Gefälligkeiten zu erkaufen um
in einem regulatorischen Klima
Vergünstigungen zu erhalten
ich weiß dass viele Verbraucherschützer
ist gut meinen wenn sie sagen wir
brauchen mehr auf sich wir brauchen mehr
Vorschriften für diese schlimme Sachen
die hier passiert ist
nicht wissen ist dass die Regulierung
wenn sie dann tatsächlich in Kraft tritt
und bis auf die Ebene der
landwirtschaftlichen Betriebe vordringt
immer immer immer den kleinen Erzeugern
schadet und den großen Erzeugern hilft
das ist die Drehtür wissen sie nicht
gesund essen sie nur Mist
ein paar Unternehmen kontrollieren alles
es gibt nur eine kleine Gruppe von
agrarkonzernen die die gesamte
Lebensmittelproduktion kontrollieren
sie verdrängen alle anderen aus dem
Geschäft sie wollen keine Konkurrenz
der Kleinbauer ist immer eine Bedrohung
wenn 50 Millionen Menschen in den USA
von sich aus entscheiden dass sie ihre
Produkte lieber bei Kleinbauern oder auf
Bauernmärkten kaufen weil sie sie für
gesünder halten dann ist das eine Abkehr
vom System
die Regierung will das nicht und
Monsanto will das ganz sicher auch nicht
und auch keiner der großen Agrarkonzerne
will das es ist also besser alles zu tun
um den Kleinbauern in Amerika
auszulöschen man lässt den Bankrott
gehen zwingt ihn sein Land zu verkaufen
das dann von einem größeren
Agrarunternehmen übernommen wird bis
schließlich die gesamte Nahrungskette
von großen Konzernen und der Regierung
kontrolliert wird
die Vorschriften die kleinen
unabhängigen Fahrern wie der von Joel
salatin auferlegt werden haben eine
Hürde geschaffen die die Größe und den
Umfang seines Betriebes einschränkt und
ob diese Vorschriften nun gut gemeint
sind oder nur auferlegt wurden um den
großen einen unfairen Vorteil zu
verschaffen das Endergebnis ist dass
viele Produkte die Joel gerne verkaufen
würde als illegal eingestuft wurden
die Dinge die wir gerne tun würden vom
Pökeln von Fleisch bis zum Verkauf von
Rohmilch zum Beispiel die würden gerne
Rohmilch verkaufen und wir haben Kunden
die gerne Rohmilch bekommen würden aber
es ist illegal wir hatten gerade einen
Inspektor des Gesundheitsamtes hier der
uns sagte dass unser geflügelschlachthof
illegal sei und er uns schließen will
sie waren der Meinung dass es von Natur
aus unhygienisch ist wenn der Stall zu
Luft hin offen ist
[Musik]
das faszinierende ist dass ein
Futterlager unter erbärmlichen
Bedingungen und mit Verbotsschildern
fast mit allem durchkommt
sind draußen wissen Sie hier draußen
macht uns das anfällig für den
Anthropomorphismus ignoranter Menschen
sie denken wahrscheinlich dass diese
landwirtschaftlichen Verordnungen für
sie bedeutungslos sind wenn diese
Verordnungen ihre Wahlmöglichkeiten
einschränken wie kommt es dann dass sie
in jedem Gang des Supermarkts Dutzende
von verschiedenen Marken und hunderte
von verschiedenen Lebensmitteln finden
können ich meine wie viel Auswahl
brauchen wir denn
[Musik]
der Durchschnittsmensch geht in den
Supermarkt und er sieht all dieses Zeug
in den Regalen und er denkt sich was
soll das heißen ich habe keine Auswahl
ich kann kaum chocula Frühstücksflocken
fruit Loops Cracker Jacks was auch immer
bekommen ich kann Kartoffelchips von
zehn verschiedenen Firmen bekommen was
soll das heißen ich habe keine Auswahl
es ist also schwer zu verkaufen weil es
den Leuten schwer fällt zu verstehen was
sie nicht bekommen können
ist was man nicht bekommen kann ist
Geflügel das im Hinterhof geschlachtet
wurde und nicht durch eine große
Verarbeitungsanlage gelaufen ist
es gibt eine enorme Menge an
handwerklich hergestellten Lebensmitteln
die jetzt nicht mehr erhältlich sind
weil sie kriminalisiert und verboten
wurden
letztendlich geht es um das Risiko
manche Dinge wie Rummel sind einfach zu
riskant um sie an die Öffentlichkeit zu
bringen
schließlich könnte verunreinigte
Rohmilch theoretisch so schädlich sein
wie Gift
[Musik]
echtes Gift hingegen ist offenbar in
Ordnung
[Musik]
wenn man über Risiken sprechen will ist
es dann nicht faszinierend das genau die
Einrichtung die uns Insektizide beschert
hat den Rinderwahnsinn das Klonen die
Gentechnik
das sind alles sehr riskante Dinge ich
meine ob man nun daran glaubt oder nicht
man muss sich darüber im Klaren sein
dass das alles sehr risikoreiche Dinge
sind
und das sind dann diejenigen die sagen
ich setze meinen Vertrauen in Dich was
meine Nahrung betrifft
ich glaube dass die Menschen ständig
riskantes Verhalten an den Tag legen
wenn sie ihren Kindern pasteurisierte
Milch
geben
aber die Regierung hat entschieden dass
das kein riskantes Verhalten ist
riskant ist es ein Glas Rohmilch zu
trinken
wenn man es genau nimmt ist es gar nicht
so schlimm keine Rohmilch zu bekommen
ich meine wer braucht schon Rohmilch
wenn man frittierte Mozzarella Sticks
oder leckere hähnchenfinger bekommen
kann
Essen ist schließlich essen oder
man muss sich mal bewusst machen was
1979 als die erste Ernährungspyramide
vom Agrarministerium herauskam mit
Getreide ganz unten ist das der Beginn
der Adipositas und diabetes-epidemie war
weil die Kohlenhydrate ganz unten waren
es ist eine Tatsache dass Amerika heute
viel viel gesünder wäre wenn die
Regierung uns nicht gesagt hätte was wir
essen sollen
vielleicht haben sie es mit den
gesättigten Fetten und den Käse Imitat
etwas übertrieben wem kümmert das wir
haben Zugang zu den besten Medikamenten
der Welt egal ob Sie einen Ruhepuls von
116 haben ob sie nach dem dritten
Cheeseburger schwitzen wie ein Schwein
oder ob ihnen von all den Medikamenten
schlecht wird die Sie einnehmen es gibt
Mittel die Ihnen helfen
und wir sind uns alle einig dass es
einen Bereich gibt in dem wir strenge
Vorschriften brauchen Arzneimittel
schließlich will niemand das unsichere
Medikamente an die Öffentlichkeit
gelangen
es gibt natürlich viele Medikamente die
hilfreich sind aber was mich beunruhigt
ist das gegen eine bedeutende Minderheit
von Medikamenten die von der
Arzneimittelbehörde zugelassen wurden
die eigenen medizinischen Prüfer
Einwände hatten aus Sicherheitsgründen
viele unsichere Medikamente sind auf dem
Markt zugelassen worden die tatsächlich
zum Tod führen zu Leber Versagen
Nierenversagen Herzinfarkten diese
Medikamente sind auf dem Markt viele von
ihnen immer noch und werden jedes Jahr
neu zugelassen
wir verdanken es den strengen
Qualitätskontrollen der
Arzneimittelbehörde das ein Medikament
wie Weiher das über 100.000 Herzinfarkte
und Zehntausende von Todesfällen
verursacht hat schnell vom Markt
genommen wurde nach nur fünf Jahren
und 2,5
wenn ein Behördenmitarbeiter wissentlich
ein unsicheres Medikament wie wirkt
genehmigt und es auf dem Markt beläst
obwohl es 140.000 Herzinfarkte und
60.000 Todesfälle gibt und trotzdem
dieses Unternehmen merk verteidigt dann
stimmt hier etwas nicht da läuft
irgendetwas furchtbar falsch warum kann
diese Person nicht zur Rechenschaft
gezogen werden sie kommen damit durch
sie kommen nicht nur ungestraft davon
sondern im Fall des Mitarbeiters der das
getan hat läster Crawford wird er
schließlich von einer Firma namens
policy directions angestellt in einer
sehr hohen Position und diese Firma
vertritt mag
[Musik]
vielleicht war der weihnachtsvorfall nur
ein einmaliges Ereignis es gibt viele
hilfreiche Medikamente auf dem Markt und
die Behörde sollte nicht wegen eines
kleinen Ausrutschers unter die Lupe
genommen werden ich meine es ist ja
nicht so dass so etwas regelmäßig
vorkommt
die Behörde sagt dass alle Medikamente
die es in Amerika gibt sicher und
wirksam sind
so kommen Sie in die Arztpraxen und
Apotheken und deshalb nehmen die
Menschen sie ein
Dankeschön
nun 106.000 Menschen werden jedes Jahr
in den USA durch von der Behörde
zugelassenen Medikamente getötet die
Behörde räumt das auf ihre eigenen
Website ein aber sie sagt nichts darüber
dass sie die Verantwortung dafür
übernimmt für sie ist das nur eine
weitere medizinische Tatsache
über 100.000 Todesfälle durch
verschreibungspflichtige Medikamente
jedes Jahr man sollte meinen dass die
Behörde bei all den strengenden Tests
die sie durchführt bevor Sie ein
Medikament auf den Markt bringt einige
dieser lebensbedrohlichen Nebenwirkungen
entdecken würde
das sind die Flaschen die schließlich
ihren Weg in die Arztpraxen und Kliniken
im ganzen Land finden werden noch
während sie das Ende der
Produktionslinie erreichen laufen
weitere Tests und werden Proben an die
Regierung geschickt
das Protokoll des Herstellers wird
überprüft und dann einer ganzen Reihe
von komplexen wissenschaftlichen Tests
unterzogen
das gesamte System der
Arzneimittelprüfung durch die Behörde
ist ein Schwindel es ist darauf
ausgelegt die Interessen der
Arzneimittelindustrie zu schützen viele
Menschen sind sich dessen nicht bewusst
aber die Behörde testet die von ihr
zugelassenen Medikamente nie sie führt
überhaupt keine unabhängigen Tests durch
sie verlässt sich ganz auf die Tests die
von den Befürwortern des Arzneimittels
durchgeführt werden also von denjenigen
die den Antrag auf Zulassung gestellt
haben die ein Eigeninteresse haben sie
werden für alle arzneimitteltest
herangezogen sie führen ihre eigenen
Tests durch
die Behörde führt also keine
unabhängigen Tests für die von ihr
zugelassenen Medikamente durch aber kann
man es ihnen verübeln dass sie bei so
vielen neuen Medikamenten die Tests an
die herstellerauslagern
denn wenn man eine Milliarden schweren
Pharmakonzern nicht trauen kann wen dann
es hat mehrere Fälle von Korruptionen in
diesem Prozess gegeben in denen negative
Informationen von der Behörde
ferngehalten wurden damit Sie ein
Medikament zulässt so hört sich seine
vier Eventis bei seinem Medikament
Kritik hauptsächlich auf eine klinische
Studie gestürzt von der die
medizinischen Gutachter der Behörde die
den Fall unter die Lupe nahmen
herausfanden dass sie gar nicht
stattgefunden hatte sie haben sie
erfunden
es gab Ermittlungen des FBI und
strafrechtliche Verfolgung aber was hat
die Behörde getan die medizinischen
Gutachter sagten meine Güte sie haben
sich bei diesem Antrag auf einen Betrug
verlassen wir sollten ihn ablehnen aber
die behördenkommission genehmigte ihn
sie brachte kitek auf den Markt sie
sehen also es ist dieser Grad an
Einfluss und Korruption der ist
unmöglich macht das amerikanische Volk
zu schützen
[Musik]
angesichts der Tatsache dass Medikamente
von der Behörde trotz der Einwände ihre
eigenen Gutachter zugelassen werden kann
es kaum einen Zweifel daran geben dass
die Drehtür in der pharmazeutischen
Industrie lebendig und gesund ist und
für den Fall dass sie doch noch einen
winzigen Funken Zweifel haben denken Sie
an den Fall Billy
sie sollten vielleicht ein paar
Tabletten gegen Übelkeit bereithalten
der Kongress Abgeordnete Billy tarsin
der dem Energie und
handelsausschussvorstand sollte dafür
sorgen dass ein Absatz in das Gesetz
aufgenommen wird der die gesamte
Regierung daran hindert den Stückpreis
für Medikamente herunterzuhandeln die im
Rahmen von Medicare Partie erworben
werden müssen
mit anderen Worten sie sind gezwungen
den Preis zu zahlen den die
Pharmaindustrie pro Einheit für die im
Rahmen von Medicare Partie gekauften
Medikamente festlegt das könnte die
Pharmaindustrie in die Lage versetzen
die Nation nach Belieben finanziell in
die Knie zu zwingen und so kam es dass
dieser Absatz in der buschregierung in
das Gesetz aufgenommen wurde tars in die
Regierung verließ seinen Posten im
Kongress aufgab Chef des
us-pharma-verbands wurde und das höchste
Gehalt erhielt das bis dahin jemals
gezahlt worden war 2,5 Millionen Dollar
pro Jahr als Belohnung für seinen
Ausverkauf der Nation zum Schutz der
Pharmaindustrie
auch wenn die Regierung die Lebensmittel
und Medikamente die sie für Sicherheit
oft schlecht auswählt so versucht sie
zumindest nicht uns etwas davon
aufzuzwingen
ist Abgeordneter des
Repräsentantenhauses von New Hampshire
und einer der führenden Befürworter von
Impfungen in seinem Bundesstaat
Repräsentantenhaus kam fragte mich
jemand ob ich an einem Gesetzentwurf zur
freiwilligen Impfung arbeiten würde dann
fand ich heraus dass man bei einer
Epidemie alle Menschen zu einer Impfung
zwingen kann
in den USA wird zurzeit darüber
gestritten ob man eine Impfpflicht
einführen kann da jeder Bundesstaat
seine eigenen Ausnahmeregelungen hat die
Eltern in Anspruch nehmen können aber
jetzt wird versucht zu sagen wir werden
euch zwingen euch impfen zu lassen ob
ihr wollt oder nicht ihr habt nicht die
Freiheit zu entscheiden
wenn wir über medizinische Sicherheit
und Freiheit sprechen sollte jeder die
Wahl haben welche Verfahren er möchte
man kann eine medizinische Ausnahme
bekommen man kann eine religiöse
Ausnahme bekommen aber keine aus
Gewissensgründen vor ein paar Jahren
hatten wir in johannsha ein Problem mit
Spritzen die möglicherweise mit
Meningitis verunreinigt waren aber wenn
man geimpft oder gespritzt werden muss
woher weiß man dann dass die Spritze
nicht verunreinigt ist
wenn Sie wollen dass ihre Kinder zur
Schule gehen oder an anderen Aktivitäten
teilnehmen sagt die Regierung dass sie
das tun müssen oder ausgeschlossen
werden das ist ein Problem denn wenn man
in den Nachrichten hört dass es etwas
gibt dass das Leben gefährdet sollte man
in der Lage sein eine fundierte
Entscheidung zu treffen
[Musik]
das ist es worauf Freiheit letztendlich
hinausläuft die Freiheit zu entscheiden
wie man leben möchte ob zum Guten oder
zum Schlechten und diese Freiheit sollte
nicht von der Regierung außer Kraft
gesetzt werden außer in den extremsten
Fällen oder um uns vor teuflischen
Bedrohungen zu schützen
[Musik]
Kurzhaar egal wie man es nennt egal mit
welchen hippen Straßennamen man es
bezeichnet es kommt alles aus demselben
Versteck
es ist alles Marihuana
Marihuana es ist eine der gefährlichsten
Drogen die die Menschheit kennt und für
fast so viele Todesfälle pro Jahr
verantwortlich wie Asteroiden oder
heilangriffe es kann bei ansonsten
gesunden Erwachsenen zu Lachkrämpfen und
Hunger führen
zum Glück führen die tapferen Männer und
Frauen zahlreicher Behörden seit
Jahrzehnten einen unermüdlichen und
teuren Krieg gegen diese gefährliche
Pflanze
der Krieg gegen Drogen ist ein Krieg
gegen die Menschen es ist ein Krieg der
für die Pharmaindustrie geführt wird
damit sie ihre Psychopharmaka verkaufen
kann ich meine Herr Gott von wie vielen
Leuten habe ich Horrorgeschichten gehört
dass sich ihre Kinder mit weikutin zu
dröhnen oh das ist doch Quatsch wie wäre
es mit ein bisschen Oxycodon um Dich
glücklich zu machen hast du Schmerzen
damit gehen sie weg aber werd nicht heim
an kein Gras das wird dich umbringen du
hast Griefer Madness gesehen
[Musik]
Griefer Madness ist ein berühmter für
die US-Regierung produzierter Film der
bekannt ist für seine unvoreingenommene
angehensweise an das Thema Marihuana
von dem er behauptet es sei schlimmer
als Heroin und der Generationen vor den
Gefahren von Marihuana bewahrt schon ein
einziger Zug Mary Jane kann dich dazu
bringen wie ein Narr zu tanzen
unkontrolliert zu lachen
oder deine Freunde gewaltsam zu ermorden
wie peinlich
ist eine gemeinnützige Organisation
deren Ziel die Legalisierung von
Cannabis in den gesamten USA ist
jedes Jahr werden in den Vereinigten
Staaten 800.000 Menschen wegen Marihuana
verhaftet 90 Prozent davon nur wegen
Besitzes über einen Zeitraum von 40
Jahren sind also etwa 27 Millionen
Menschen wegen Marihuana verhaftet
worden so dass ein riesiges Universum
von Menschen entstanden ist die effektiv
von der Regierung verarscht worden sind
[Musik]
als wir die Drogenbehörde verklagten
entschied der Richter 1988 in seinem
endgültigen Urteil das Marihuana die
sicherste therapeutische Substanz ist
die den Menschen bekannt ist
das ist eine ziemlich starke Anklage
gegen alle anderen Drogen
die Gerichte haben also anerkannt dass
Marihuana die sicherste therapeutische
Substanz ist die dem Menschen bekannt
ist aber schon seit den 30er Jahren war
Marihuana Gegenstand zahlloser
schwerwiegender und irreführender
Propaganda
langfristiger Konsum von Marihuana kann
zu einer psychischen Abhängigkeit führen
du wirst alles mögliche Versuche Nummern
deinen Stoff zu kommen die Leute fangen
an dich mit Namen wie potat oder Smokie
Mac Bong water zu beschimpfen da du
jegliche Motivation verlierst brichst du
wahrscheinlich die Schule ab entwickelst
eine Vorliebe für cita Music und wirst
vielleicht sogar von ein oder zwei
Polizisten angefasst
mit Marihuana machen die US-Regierung
und ihre Stellvertreter auf staatlicher
Ebene seit mindestens 75 Jahren
Propaganda es gibt 1200 Annoncen der
partnership for drug free America und 85
bis 90 Prozent dieser Annoncen waren
gegen Marihuana
und allein der Name drug free America
verdient nichts anderes als reines
Gelächter ein drogenfreies Amerika dies
ist die drogensüchtigste Gesellschaft in
der Geschichte der Menschheit und der
Verband für ein drogenfreies Amerika
wurde ursprünglich von den Alkohol Tabak
und Pharmakonzernen gegründet deren
Geschäftsmodell so weit ich weiß der
Vertrieb von Drogen ist
abgesehen von den persönlichen Gefühlen
gegenüber Marihuana lässt sich die
Tatsache nicht leugnen dass die
Kriminalisierung dieser Substanz kaum
mit anderen Substanzen im gleichen
Bereich wie Alkohol oder Tabak
vergleichbar ist aber wer profitiert von
den Millionen die für die Verhinderung
des Konsums und die strafrechtliche
Verfolgung der Konsumenten ausgegeben
werden
es gibt Einrichtungen die sich stark für
die Beibehaltung des Status quo
einsetzen die Strafverfolgungsbehörden
die Regierungsbehörden die aus der
Prohibition hervorgegangen sind wie die
partnership vor Truck free America das
drogenpräventionsprogramm die
Drogenbehörde sie werden immer gegen die
Legalisierung sein die dritte Gruppe
sind die Alkohol Tabak und
Pharmakonzerne sozusagen der lachende
Dritte sie versuchen Dinge wie die
Partnerschaft für ein drogenfreies
amerikans Leben zu rufen aber sie wollen
ganz sicher kein drogenfreies Amerika
die vierte Gruppe sind Unternehmen die
mit der Prohibition Geld verdienen also
private Gefängnisse und
drogentestunternehmen das ist
wahrscheinlich die offensichtlichste
Opposition denn wenn man mit Marihuana
erwischt wird kann man entweder den Weg
der Strafverfolgung und einer möglichen
Verurteilung wählen und dann ins
Gefängnis gehen oder man geht in den
Entzug
der Direktor von Norma sagte wenn ich
mit einer kleinen Menge Marihuana
erwischt werden würde würde ich mich für
den Entzug entscheiden wenn ich die Wahl
hätte und so werden Ihnen 80% der
Klientel von der Regierung praktisch auf
dem Silbertablett serviert
es handelt sich um eine inzestulse
Beziehung zwischen den Profiteuren der
Drogen Rehabilitation und der Regierung
die die Klienten direkt bis zur Tür
bringt und wir die Steuerzahler zahlen
für die Rehabilitation
in der Sprache die die Süchtigen
untereinander verwenden sagen sie nie
lass uns eine Marihuana Zigarette
rauchen sie sagen let's oder Let's Play
wie das Trinken von Rohmilch wirkt auch
das Rauchen einer Marihuana Zigarette
offensichtliche Gesundheitsrisiken aber
ob Sie nun einen Joint rauchen oder
einen im Freien geschlachtetes Huhn von
Ihrem örtlichen Bauern kaufen wollen
mächtige Lobbygruppen haben sich mit den
Behörden abgesprochen um ihre
Entscheidungsfreiheit einzuschränken
wenn die Regierung ihnen gewaltsam die
Tür Eintritt und mitgezogenen Waffen auf
ihr Grundstück kommt um sie dazu zu
bringen ein bestimmtes Verhalten
einzustellen dass niemandem sonst
schadet ist das eine soziale
Ungerechtigkeit
ich betrachte es im Moment fast
ausschließlich als eine Diskussion über
persönliche Freiheit und darüber wie
sehr sich die Regierung in dein Leben
einmischen darf und zwar gewaltsam und
mit gezogenen Pistolen
okay wir haben viel über Essen und
Medizin und Lobo gesprochen aber genug
von diesem hippie-geräte jeder weiß dass
ich die Welt nur um eine Sache dreht und
zwar um mich
ich meine Geld
aber ähnlich wie unabhängige Landwirte
sind auch kleine Unternehmen im
Finanzsektor mit strengen Vorschriften
konfrontiert von denen die großen
Akteure profitieren
ich bin in der wertpapierbranche tätig
und es gibt alle möglichen Vorschriften
an die ich mich halten muss die meisten
davon schützen meine Kunden die
einzelnen Anleger nicht aber das ist
nicht der Grund warum ich glaube dass es
sie gibt es ist die Ausrede die die
Politiker den Wählern geben der wahre
Grund ist dass es sehr große Banken und
Maklerfirmen gibt die es nicht mögen
wenn kleine Firmen wie meine mit ihnen
konkurrieren deshalb wollen sie uns mit
bürokratischen Hürden behindern sie
können es sich leisten für die
Vorschriften zu bezahlen kleine Firmen
können das nicht sie haben es nicht
getan um den Anlegern zu helfen sondern
um den großen Maklerfirmen zu helfen die
sich vor der Konkurrenz schützen wollen
die Drehtür ist dass wenn diese Leute
Washington verlassen Sie bequeme Jobs
bei den Firmen bekommen die sie früher
reguliert haben
sie wechseln von der Industrie zur
Regierung zurück zu Industrie und zu
Regierung was sie tun ist dass sie mit
ihrem Einfluss hausieren gehen
sie gehen nach Washington um Einfluss zu
gewinnen um sich Freunde zu machen und
dann verkaufen sie ihren Einfluss an den
Meistbietenden wenn sie wieder gehen
traurigerweise ist die Finanzindustrie
vielleicht das beste Beispiel für die
Verflechtung von Regierung und
Großunternehmen
so wurde zum Beispiel berichtet dass der
Finanzminister jacoblu von seinem
früheren Arbeitgeber der Citigroup einen
Bonus von 950.000 Dollar bekam nur weil
er einen Job im Finanzministerium annahm
während seiner Zeit als Betriebsleiter
bei der City Group beaufsichtigte Jacob
blue den Hedgefonds der auf den
Zusammenbruch des Immobilienmarktes
wettete die City Group die drittgrößte
Bank in den USA erhielt 2008 45
Milliarden Dollar an rettungsgeldern
[Musik]
wenn Sie den Beweis für den Faschismus
sehen wollen brauchen Sie nur vier
einfache Worte zu lesen zu groß zum
Scheitern die Verschmelzung von
staatlicher und unternehmerischer macht
als Amerika 2008 eine Finanzkrise hatte
änderte sich das ganze Spiel
[Musik]
die Banken gerieten in Schwierigkeiten
sie holten Henry Paulsen den
US-Finanzminister und ehemaligen
Vorstandsvorsitzenden von Goldman Sachs
und der sagte wir müssen die Banken sie
sind zu groß um zu scheitern
im November 2007 ernannte Präsident Bush
Nil kaskari zum stellvertretenden
Finanzminister für internationale
Wirtschaft und Entwicklung kaskari
verfasste und beaufsichtigte das
troubled asset Relief program dass die
Rettung der Wall Street ermöglichte
kaskari auch der bailort Saar genannt
war Investmentbanker bei Goldman Sachs
[Musik]
von 2008 war der größte wirtschaftliche
Zusammenbruch seit der Großen Depression
mitten in der Krise forderten die
Finanz-
der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler Peter
Schiff der die Krise jahrelang
vorausgesagt hat ist der Meinung dass
nicht nur die Wall Street die Schuld
trägt sondern das vor allem die
Regulierungsbehörden die mit der
Finanzindustrie zusammenarbeiten für die
Krise verantwortlich sind
[Musik]
die Regulierungsbehörden haben die Krise
verursacht es war die Regulierung die
das Problem geschaffen hat ich habe 2002
drei vier fünf sechs über die kommende
Immobilienkrise gesprochen und genau
aufgezeigt wie die Regierung und die
Zentralbank das Problem verursacht haben
die Leute die jetzt sagen wir hätten
nicht genug Regulierung wo waren die
damals warum haben sie 2005 nicht gesagt
dass wir mehr Regulierung brauchen
tatsache ist dass das Problem durch die
bestehenden Vorschriften verursacht
wurde
um die Wirtschaft anzukurbeln hat die
Zentralbank die Zinsen auf 1% gesenkt
das ermöglichte es den Leuten sich
billiger Geld zu leihen um Häuser zu
kaufen in der Zwischenzeit garantierte
die Regierung auch die Hypotheken und
das war das eigentliche Problem
die Art und Weise wie der Markt die
Banken reguliert besteht darin dass die
Menschen ihr Geld sicher aufbewahren
wollen und sich daher nach einem
sicheren Ort umsehen daher zwingt der
Druck des Marktes die Banken zu Vorsicht
um Einlagen anzuziehen sobald jedoch die
Regierung auf dem Plan tritt und sagt
dass Ihr Geld sicher ist egal was
passiert legt der Kunde keinen Wert mehr
auf Sicherheit weil die Regierung Sie
garantiert das Problem mit der
staatlichen Regulierung ist aber dass
sie in effektiv ist und am Ende
politisiert wird denn wenn Sie sich
daran erinnern dass während der Zeit des
Immobilienmarktes die Kreditvergabe
Standards immer weiter gesenkt wurden
war es die Regierung die den Vorstoß zur
Senkung der Standards unternahm weil die
Wähler mehr Häuser kaufen wollten weil
der familienmarkt als seine Möglichkeit
angesehen wurde reich zu werden und das
einzige Hindernis war die Anzahlung die
Kreditwürdigkeit und so war es die
Regierung die Druck auf die Banken
ausübte hey vergesst die
Kreditwürdigkeit senkt die Anzahlungen
also kümmert sich niemand um irgendwas
weil die Regierung versucht alles gut zu
machen die Regierung sagt macht euch
keine Sorgen um das Risiko denn wenn ihr
scheitert sind wir da um euch
aufzufangen und wenn das nicht
funktioniert bekommt der Kapitalismus
einen schlechten Ruf als ob das alles
irgendwas mit Kapitalismus zu tun hatte
wenn wir ins Jahr 2011 springen finden
wir die Geschichte von MF Global einem
rohstoffmakler Unternehmen das vom
ehemaligen Gouverneur von New Jersey
John core sein geleitet wird
keine angenehme Rückkehr zum capital
Hill er wurde vorgeladen um den
Gesetzgebern mitzuteilen wie das von ihm
geleitete Unternehmen MF Global
zusammenbrach und was mit 1,2 Milliarden
Dollar an Kundengeldern geschah ich weiß
einfach nicht wo das Geld ist oder warum
die konnten bis heute nicht abgeglichen
wurden
hassen sie es nicht auch wenn Sie Ihre
Schlüssel Ihr Telefon oder das Geld
anderer Leute in Höhe von einer
Milliarde Dollar nicht finden können das
ist so frustrierend
aber so unangenehm ist für corsine auch
gewesen sein mag dort zu sitzen und so
zu tun als ob er sich schlecht fühlte so
fühlten sich andere von der Situation
noch ein wenig mehr angegriffen
ich bin durch den MF Global Skandal
verbrannt worden
John core sein der ehemalige
demokratische governa von New Jersey
der ehemalige Senator von New Jersey und
der ehemalige Chef der Goldman Sachs
Bande
nachdem er eine Zeit lang bei denen war
wurde er der Chef von MF Global ja MF
perfekt
im sechsstelligen Bereich ich habe hart
für mein Geld gearbeitet ich habe nicht
an den Märkten spekuliert er hat mein
Geld gestohlen
als er untersuchte wie dieses Geld von
seinem Konto gestohlen wurde ohne dass
die Finanzaufsichtsbehörden Eingriffen
stieß er bei seinen Nachforschungen auf
das verräterische Quietschen der Drehtür
die
Behörde die Maklerfirmen wie MF Global
reguliert
zum Zeitpunkt des mf-raubes wurde die
cfdc von einem gewissen Gary Gensler
geleitet einem engen Kollegen von Corsa
hat sein Team nicht ein einziges Mal
vergessen lassen worum es hier
eigentlich geht das amerikanische Volk
wissen Sie was die cfdc mit John gemacht
hat nachdem er mich und Tausende von
anderen beraubt hatte nichts gar
nichtsler war sein Lieutenant bei
Goldman Sachs und er ist der Kopf der
FTC
den Hühnerstall bewacht ist dumm das ist
es ist noch schlimmer
[Musik]
der Zusammenbruch von MF Global ist ein
Beispiel für die Allianz zwischen
Aufsichtsbehörden und Großunternehmen in
der Finanzbranche
aber ein noch beunruhigenderes Phänomen
ein sogenanntes
selbst bei meinen düstersten Vorhersagen
die ich im Laufe der Jahre in diesem
Parlament über das Verhalten der
eu-bosse gemacht habe hätte ich nie
gedacht dass sie in einer noch nie
dagewesenen Weise dazu übergehen würden
Geld von den Bankkonten der Bürger zu
stellen
in Zypern haben die Banken
unverantwortlich gehandelt und die
Öffentlichkeit alle Einleger haben den
Preis dafür bezahlt sie nannten es einen
Bale in um es anders klingen zu lassen
als einen Bale out
was passierte war dass viele der Banken
in Zypern eine Menge griechischer
Staatsanleihen kauften und die
griechischen Staatsanleihen sind in den
letzten Jahren fast zusammengebrochen
dadurch wurden diese zypriotischen
Banken fast zahlungsunfähig und sie
gingen wie immer zur Regierung und
sagten hey wir sind pleite könnt ihr uns
helfen und Geld für uns stehen und genau
das haben sie getan sie sagten einfach
nimm 50% von allem über 100.000 $, nimmt
die Hälfte von ihrem Geld nimmt es
einfach
allein der Begriff bailin ist eine Lüge
das ist ein Marketinginstrument um im
Grunde einen Diebstahl zu vertuschen
bei einem bell-out wird das Geld
aufgepeppt und den Banken gegeben und
die Öffentlichkeit zahlt letztendlich
dafür durch eine Steuer die Inflation
genannt wird weil es jetzt mehr Geld
gibt bei einem bailin überspringt man
den Teil der Geldschöpfung und nimmt es
einfach von den Einlegern aber im Grunde
gewinnen die Banken in beiden Fällen auf
Kosten der Allgemeinheit
aber das war in Zypern nicht in den USA
die Bürger Nordamerikas würden so etwas
hinterhältiges wie einen bell-in auf
keinen Fall zulassen
okay dann Kanada hat in seinen Haushalt
2013 eine Bale in Klausel aufgenommen
die besagt dass wenn die kanadischen
Banken Probleme haben sie das Geld
einfach von den Bürgern nehmen können
die USA haben ebenfalls darüber
gesprochen die Regierungen erlauben den
Banken so was zu tun
Zypern war das Modell um zu sehen ob sie
damit durchkommen sie sind damit
durchgekommen und jetzt hat es sich als
erfolgreich erwiesen so dass es eine
Lösung ist die Sie in Zukunft nutzen
können
im Nachhinein scheint es offensichtlich
dass der Finanzsektor voller Korruption
und Bestechung ist das Finanzwesen das
Bildungswesen das Gefängnissystem der
militärisch industrielle Komplex fast
jede Branche in der es Geld zu verdienen
gibt ist von der Drehtür betroffen
sogar relativ neue Agenturen sind von
den Machenschaften betroffen wenn Sie
einen Beweis brauchen nehmen Sie einen
Nagelknipser mit auf einen Inlandsflug
wenn Sie zum Flughafen gehen wollen die
Agenten der transportsicherheitsbehörde
TSA in ihre Privatsphäre eindringen ihre
Taschen durchsuchen und du hast nicht
die Möglichkeit Nein zu sagen wenn du
einmal in der Schlange stehst kommst du
nicht mehr raus was ist der Sinn dieses
Systems es ist ein sicherheitstheater es
geht darum die Menschen zu verängstigen
nicht darum dass Sie sich sicher fühlen
denn je mehr man die Menschen
verängstigen kann desto mehr kann man
ihre Rechte einschränken und sie ständig
daran erinnern dass sie die Regierung
brauchen um für Ihre Sicherheit zu
sorgen
die Körperscanner die Sie daran hindern
gefährliche Gegenstände wie
Wasserflaschen mit ins Flugzeug zu
nehmen wurden aufgrund von
tsa-vorschriften installiert
als Leiter des Heimatschutzministeriums
verlangte Michael Shadow dass alle
Flughäfen des Landes mit diesen Scannern
ausgestattet werden
natürlich zu unserer Sicherheit
mit dieser Technologie können wir jeden
am Körper verborgenen Gegenstand
aufspüren auch unter der Kleidung
verstecktes Plastik
die Scanner selbst werden von einer
Firma namens rapistan gebaut und
installiert können Sie erraten wer nach
seinem Ausscheiden aus dem Heimatschutz
als Berater für rapperscan gearbeitet
hat
oh ja ich erinnere mich lassen Sie mich
überlegen
Security gleich nach dem
unterhosenbomber gleich danach
erschienen
wir müssen die Röntgengeräte
Rapid Scan somebody Scan so heißt die
Firma sie wissen schon
sie röntgen dich
oh so ein Mist
wow
Check love wurde Berater für diese Firma
nachdem er die Homeland Security
verlassen hat
okay lassen Sie uns das klarstellen
Gentechnik sicher Rohmilch unsicher
Geflügel im Freien zuzubereiten ist
unhygienisch aber Medikamente die
Herzinfarkte verursachen sind okay wenn
man einen Joint raucht will man töten am
Flughafen gerecht zu werden ist für die
nationale Sicherheit unerlässlich und
seine Kunden zu bestehlen ist okay
solange man es mit einer Milliarde
Dollar auf einmal tut
da die Regulierungsbehörden so eng mit
dem Großkapital verflochten sind ist es
fast unmöglich zu wissen ob die Regel
nach denen wir leben zu unserer
Sicherheit oder zum finanziellen Vorteil
eines anderen erlassen wurden was auch
immer der Grund ist das Endergebnis ist
dass unser Leben jetzt so stark von den
Wünschen anderer manipuliert wird dass
unsere Wahlmöglichkeiten immer mehr
eingeschränkt werden
[Musik]
genau darum geht es bei der staatlichen
Regulierung unsere Wahlmöglichkeiten
einzuschränken die Regierung will
Entscheidungen für Sie treffen Ihnen die
Freiheit der Wahl nehmen was sie essen
all das wird von der Regierung für sie
bestimmt warum können wir keine
Entscheidungen treffen darum geht es
doch bei der Freiheit die Politiker
denken das ist wichtig ist dass wir alle
wählen dass Sie uns vertrauen können
aber sie trauen uns nicht zu dass wir
Entscheidungen darüber treffen ob wir
ein Haus kaufen oder mieten welchen
Makler wir nehmen ob ich mich anschnalle
oder einen Helm trage oder ob ich
Zigaretten rauche all diese
Entscheidungen müssen von der Regierung
getroffen werden irgendwie sind wir klug
genug um zu wählen aber wir sind zu dumm
um irgendetwas anderes zu tun
diese Überregulierung hat noch andere
Auswirkungen als nur die Einschränkung
unserer Wahlmöglichkeiten dass die
Behörden die Befugnis haben unser Leben
zu regulieren sogar im Namen des
Schutzes hat so eine Ausweitung der
Regierungsmacht auf Kosten der
individuellen Freiheiten geführt
wie lautet das alte Sprichwort gib ihnen
einen Zentimeter und sie werden dir dein
Geld dein Leben und deine
lieblingsmilchprodukte wegnehmen so in
etwa
die mehr Gesetze es gibt je mehr
Vorschriften und Steuern desto weniger
Freiheit hat man das macht Freiheit aus
es ist die Freiheit von der Regierung
dann können die Menschen tun was sie
wollen sie müssen nicht tun was die
Regierung ihnen sagt
berufsbürokraten sind in der Regel
engagierte regulierungsbefürworter sie
sind Fans von staatlicher Bevormundung
von der Regierung die individuelle
Entscheidungen trifft und das Ergebnis
ist dass der einzelne seiner
Souveränität beraubt wird es macht die
Menschen zu bloßen Funktionieren des
Staates und nicht zu Menschen die ihren
eigenen Interessen nachgehen und die
Vorteile und Segnungen der Freiheit
genießen können
[Musik]
es läuft wirklich darauf hinaus wer mich
besetzt wem gehört das Individuum man
kann kein System haben dass uns die
Wahlfreiheit verweigert indem es
versucht uns vor dem Risiko einer
schlechten Wahl zu schützen und
gleichzeitig die Freiheit bewahrt gute
Entscheidungen zu treffen
genau das ist das Problem man kann nicht
beides haben Freiheit erfordert Risiko
sollte ich einen Gurt anlegen ist diese
Bank ein sicherer Ort für mein Geld
brauche ich eine Versicherung
wir sind alle so sehr mit unserem
täglichen Leben beschäftigt das wichtige
Entscheidungen zu einer überwältigenden
Herausforderung werden können viele
Menschen ziehen es vor keiner
Entscheidungen treffen zu müssen auch
wenn das bedeutet dass die
Entscheidungen die für Sie getroffen
werden nicht die besten sind
viele Menschen ziehen es vor dass die
Regierung Entscheidungen für uns trifft
anstatt selbst welche zu treffen
aber wenn der Punkt erreicht ist wie in
der ehemaligen Sowjetunion an dem der
Staat so viele Entscheidungen für einen
trifft dass er die Wirtschaft zerstört
dass er den freien Handel zerstört dass
er jeden zum Diener und den Staat zum
Herrn macht dann kommt die Menschen
irgendwann in großer Zahl zu dem Schluss
dass sie nicht bekommen was ihnen
versprochen wurde dass sie übermäßig
besteuert werden dass sie übermäßig
reguliert werden dass ihre
Wahlmöglichkeiten eingeschränkt sind
dass die Bevormundung widerlich ist dass
sie mir Kummer bereitet hat und dass ich
sie ablehnen werde ich will meine
Freiheit
bis dieser Punkt erreicht ist werden die
meisten Menschen mit ihrem bequemen
leben und denen ihnen noch zur Verfügung
stehenden Möglichkeiten zufrieden sein
die hart arbeitenden Menschen haben
keine Zeit um zu sehen oder zu hören was
vor sich geht sie arbeiten rund um die
Uhr sie versuchen über die Runden zu
kommen wofür interessiert sich Amerika
also hey wissen Sie Kim Kardashian ist
schwanger und bekommt bald ein Kind
die Medien sorgen dafür dass wir uns
nicht sehr lange mit einem wirklich
ernsten Thema aufhalten wir alle kennen
das Phänomen das ist ein sehr ernstes
Thema auftaucht dass die ernsten Aspekte
dessen was in der Welt vor sich geht
betrifft und das für einen sehr kurzen
Zeitraum in den Nachrichten auftaucht
und plötzlich wird das abgeschaltet und
wir werden mit Seifenopern und Dancing
with the stars und allen möglichen
Dingen abgelenkt die unterhaltsam sind
und ich sage nichts gegen sie aber sie
sind nicht so ernst wie zum Beispiel die
Beschneidung der Freiheit durch einen
neuen Zusatz zum Patrick
die Medien mögen ihr Bestes tun um uns
eine Fähre und ausgewogene Meinung über
das Weltgeschehen zu vermitteln aber es
gibt jetzt andere Möglichkeiten für
diejenigen die ungefilterte Nachrichten
suchen
das Netz ist sehr dezentral aufgebaut
die Macht liegt in den Händen derjenigen
die Nachrichten senden und empfangen und
nicht in den Händen derer die sie
weitergeben und das ist eine
beängstigende Aussicht für
alteingesessene Interessengruppen
[Musik]
alle alternativen Medien die nicht von
den Konzernmedien kontrolliert werden
sind eine Bedrohung
das Internet ist sicherlich eine
Bedrohung weil es fast jedem den Zugang
zur Welt ermöglicht
[Musik]
sind wir da überrascht wenn die
Politiker denen das nicht gefällt sich
ständig Gedanken darüber machen wie wir
das verhindern können
nun die Formel hat sich bewährt sie
funktioniert immer man muss den Menschen
nur sagen dass es da draußen eine
Bedrohung gibt die nur die Regierung
kontrollieren kann
es gibt eine Bedrohung durch
Kinderpornografie oder Cyberterrorismus
oder sowas wir müssen das Internet für
sie kontrollieren sonst haben sie ein
großes Problem
deshalb arbeiten sie rund um die Uhr
daran den Menschen Angst einzujagen
damit sie denken dass das Internet von
unseren guten vertrauenswürdigen
Politikern kontrolliert werden muss sie
wollen diejenigen sein die das Internet
kontrollieren und der Welt sagen was
richtig ist und was falsch
wenn man sich die Geschichte der
Kommunikationsmedien ansieht hieß es
immer das Kabelfernsehen befreit uns
endlich von der Zentralisierung das
Telegramm befreit uns
und das schlimmste Szenario wäre wenn
sich die Geschichte wiederholen würde
wenn diese erstaunliche dezentralisierte
verteilungsmethode die effektivste die
jemals in der Geschichte der Menschheit
entwickelt wurde von einer Handvoll
zentralisierter Interessenvertreter
gekapert werden würde und sie die
Kommunikation kontrollieren und
überwachen würden
[Musik]
gute Dinge sind anders als Schmelzkäse
nie von Dauer in dem betreiben einen
weiteren Teil unseres Lebens zu
regulieren sind bereits Gesetzesentwürfe
in Arbeit die versuchen das Internet zu
kontrollieren aber anstatt auf lästige
Bürokratie wie die Verabschiedung von
Gesetzen zu warten hat die Regierung
proaktiv versucht das Internet zu
zensieren natürlich zu unserer
Sicherheit mit Hilfe ihrer guten Freunde
aus der Finanzwelt wäre es ihnen zum
Beispiel fast gelungen die umstrittene
Webseite Wiki leaks zu schließen
man kann über Wikileaks denken was man
will der Punkt ist das Mitglieder der
Regierung in der Lage waren einfach mit
Zahlungsdienstleistern zu sprechen und
diese Blockade zu errichten und zu sagen
sie können kein Geld an dieser
Organisation überweisen und es ist kein
großer Sprung zu sagen moment mal die
Regierung oder in manchen Fällen
unternehmen können entscheiden dass
niemand mit diesen Leuten Geschäfte
machen kann oder dass niemand sehen kann
was diese Leute veröffentlichen das ist
offensichtlich ein Problem in unserer
Tradition der freien Meinungsäußerung
konnte überleben vor allem dank eines
sehr neuen Konzepts
dezentralisiertes Geld
im Gegensatz zu den meisten Währungen
der Welt die von den Zentralbanken
geschaffen und reguliert werden wird
dezentralisiertes Geld wie Bitcoin von
den Menschen geschaffen und ist daher
fast unmöglich zu kontrollieren
bitcoin ist eine dezentralisierte
peer-to-pear-währung es ist eigentlich
ein Internetprotokoll so ähnlich wie
SMTP mit dem man E-Mails verschickt nun
es ist Geld über das Internetprotokoll
so können wir Geld über das Internet
verschicken und wir können es nutzen um
Werte ohne einen Mittelsmann zu
übertragen das heißt wir brauchen keine
Bank oder einen Geld Übermittler wie
Western Union wir können einfach Geld
senden wie wir eine E-Mail senden
ich bin unglaublich begeistert davon
weil es das erste private Geld des
freien Marktes ist technologisches Geld
eine elektronische Währung das tolle
daran ist dass es nicht von einer
Zentralbank kontrolliert wird es ist das
Geld des Volkes und es gibt uns eine
Menge Freiheit
warum werden die Geldmenge und die
Kosten des Geldes oder die Zinssätze von
einigen Bürokraten 3000 Meilen entfernt
in Washington DC festgelegt
wie effizient ist das für unsere
Wirtschaft denn die Zinssätze regulieren
die Produktion innerhalb der Wirtschaft
ob wir sparen oder etwas bauen sollen
Bitcoin befreit diesen Zinssatz weil es
eine zensuresistente Währung ist so dass
wir ihr Geldsystem nicht mehr benutzen
müssen
dezentralisierte Währungen wie Bitcoin
bieten eine Alternative zu den
starkregulierten nationalen Währungen
der Welt aber wie bei dem Vorstoß der
Regierung das Internet zu regulieren hat
es auch schon Versuche gegeben den Kauf
von Bitcoin zu regulieren
ich habe kürzlich versucht einen Bitcoin
Automaten zu gründen ich habe einige
Anwälte angeheuert und sie sagten mir
dass man in den USA unter fünf
verschiedene Regulierungsbehörden fällt
Bankwesen Finanzwesen Geldwesen sogar
Telekommunikation weil wir das Internet
nutzen wir haben uns die Gesamtkosten
angeschaut nur um einen einfachen
Bitcoin Geldautomaten zu starten nicht
weniger als 25 Millionen Dollar weil wir
alle möglichen versicherungsgarantien
brauchen auf diese Weise halten Sie die
Konkurrenz fern weil sie keine
Konkurrenz wollen
diese versuche immer mehr Bereiche
unseres persönlichen Lebens zu
kontrollieren beunruhigen einige Leute
sehr und mit jedem neuen Gesetz oder
jeder neuen Verordnung wird die
Versuchung immer größer ganz
auszusteigen
es gibt einige Leute die das Schiff
verlassen sie sehen das ist singt und
Sie wissen nicht ob es untergehen wird
oder sich irgendwie über Wasser halten
kann sie wollen nicht in der Nähe
bleiben um das herauszufinden ich werde
niemandem sagen dass er nicht gehen soll
weil ich nicht genau weiß wie schlimm es
werden kann
Jeff burrick hat sich bereits für den
Ausstieg entschieden er hat eine
expert-gemeinschaft in Chile gegründet
um einen Zufluchtsort für
freiheitslebende Menschen zu schaffen
die die Einmischung der Regierungen
Ihrer persönlichen Angelegenheiten nicht
länger hinnehmen wollen
wir haben diese Gemeinschaft gegründet
weil wir erkannt haben dass viele
Menschen aus diesen westlichen Ländern
weg wollen steigende Steuern zunehmende
Regulierung Menschen werden in den USA
ständig für nichts in den Knast gesteckt
für Verbrechen ohne Opfer die Leute
haben nichts getan außer vielleicht
Rohmilch zu trinken oder ein paar
Pflanzen namens Marihuana in der Tasche
zu haben den wir hier anziehen wollen
das sind freiheitsliebende Menschen
jeder hat seine ganz persönliche
Geschichte der eine wurde in einem Monat
zehnmal angehalten und durchsucht kennt
dem anderen wurde durch Regulierung und
Faschismus sein gesamtes Geschäft
weggenommen kürzlich
kam ein Arzt her der der eine Praxis in
den USA hatte er hatte einen fast
hundertprozentige Heilungsrate bei Krebs
und eines Tages kamen 30
mit so viele Leute haben einfach genug
davon herumgeschubst gestohlen
geschlagen und umsonst in Käfige
gesteckt zu werden das ihnen in der
Großteil ihres Geldes und manchmal sogar
ihre ganze Existenzgrundlage genommen
wird
[Musik]
nicht jeder von uns kann einfach sein
Leben einpacken und nach Chile ziehen
welche praktischen Möglichkeiten gibt es
also noch ein guter Ansatzpunkt ist es
die Wurzel des Problems zu
identifizieren
das Problem ist dass es eine
Verschmelzung von Privatwirtschaft und
Regierung gibt und die einzige
Möglichkeit diese zu durchbrechen
besteht darin die Macht des Staates zu
beschränken wenn man dem Staat erst
einmal die Macht über unser Leben in all
diesen Bereichen gibt dann gibt es
keinen Halten mehr
dann werden die Leute die in den
Bereichen Medizin Geld Banken Strom Gas
und Öl all diese Dienstleistungen
anbieten zur Regierung gehen Politiker
kaufen die Gesetze in Ihrem Interesse
verabschieden und die durchschnittliche
Kaugummi kauen der Öffentlichkeit denkt
oh das ist nicht nett nun wir haben für
diese Leute gestimmt also ist es wohl in
unserem besten Interesse sie verstehen
es nicht wenn man den politischen Ämtern
die ganze Verlockung die ganze Macht
nimmt dann werden die einzigen Leute die
sich darauf einlassen diejenigen seien
die ihrem Land dienen wollen weil es
keine Möglichkeit mehr gibt etwas zu
stehlen
die einzige Idee die ich habe um die
Regierung zu verkleinern ist in den
Vereinigten Staaten haben wir eine
Verfassung aber jede Regierung könnte
eine Art von Verfassungszusatz oder was
auch immer verabschieden der besagt dass
Sie für jedes Gesetz oder jede
Verordnung die diese Spinner
verabschieden wollen zwei alte Gesetze
Akten oder Verordnungen finden müssen
die sie aufheben müssen das ist der
einzige Weg den ich mir vorstellen kann
um die Regierung kleiner zu machen und
das gleiche gilt für alle Behörden wenn
Sie eine andere Behörde oder Abteilung
eröffnen wollen müssen sie zwei
schließen
die individuelle Freiheit ist das was
die Menschheit ausmacht Gesetze und
Vorschriften können uns zwar das Gefühl
geben vor Bedrohungen sicher zu sein
aber alle Sicherheit der Welt bedeutet
nichts ohne die Freiheit so zu leben wie
man will
die Freiheit ist die wichtigste und
unverzichtbare Eigenschaft des Menschen
wir können durch Versprechungen der
Regierung dazu gebracht werden von
unserer Freiheit abzuweichen aber es
gibt nichts schlimmeres für den
Einzelnen als wenn ihm etwas verweigert
wird dass er dringend braucht weil er
sich zuvor entschieden hat auf seine
Freiheit zu verzichten
wenn sie unheilbar krank sind und
plötzlich feststellen dass sie nur
Zugang zu zugelassenen Behandlungen für
ihre Krankheit haben und ihnen von den
behandelnden Ärzten gesagt wird dass es
kein Medikament zur Behandlung ihrer
Krankheit gibt
um zu überleben müssen Sie also etwas
anderes finden
und sie stellen fest dass ihr Wunsch und
ihre Entscheidungsfähigkeit dieses Ziel
zu erreichen von der Arzneimittelbehörde
blockiert wird wenn Sie also Ihre
Freiheit am meisten brauchen wird sie
ihnen genommen wenn sie zu einer Familie
gehören die seit 300 Jahren oder mehr
eine Milchfarm hat und plötzlich kommen
Bundesbeamte und führen eine Razzia auf
ihrer Farm durch als wären sie ein
Drogenboss der internationale
Drogengeschäfte verwickelt ist und sie
verkaufen nur Milch
dann merken sie dass ihr ganzes Leben
auf den Kopf gestellt wurde oder sie
sind ein Kleinunternehmer der feststellt
dass sie für den Betrieb einer
Tankstelle Vorschriften einhalten müssen
die sie mehr kosten als sie mit der
Tankstelle verdienen
oder sie wollen einen
Lebensmittelbetrieb ein Restaurant
betreiben und sie entdecken dass die
staatlichen und lokalen Vorschriften so
umfangreich sind dass sie Anwälte
Buchhalter und speziell für die
Einhaltung der Vorschriften geschulte
Personen brauchen
und Sie müssen all diese Formulare
ausfüllen und Sie müssen all diese
Gebühren zahlen und sie brauchen
separate Lizenzen nur um Lebensmittel
weiter zu verkaufen die andere bereits
hergestellt und auf den Markt gebracht
haben
das ist das Ende der Freiheit
wie man die Freiheit zurückgewinnt ist
eine große Frage
der einzelne weiß dass er oder sie am
Leben ist
der einzelne weiß dass er frei ist eine
Zukunft und ein Leben zu wählen
das er will
entweder wir haben freie Gesellschaften
oder wir haben keine entweder gibt es so
etwas wie individuelle Freiheit oder es
gibt sie nicht das ist die Quintessenz
wenn man ein Leben ein richtiges Leben
führen will
dann muss es Freiheit geben
deshalb müssen die Menschen aktiv werden
wenn sie die individuelle Freiheit in
irgendeinem Bereich menschlicher
Aktivitäten bedroht sehen
das ist der Ausgangspunkt
als ich aufwuchs war New York eine
hässliche Stadt in der es viel Gewalt
gab und die Leute räumten auf indem Sie
auf die Straße Gängen und sagten nie
wieder das hat funktioniert um die
Banden zu stoppen das gleiche
funktioniert wenn man ehrliche Leute
findet die sich in der Regierung
engagieren und vielleicht können wir
dann die regierungsbanden davon abhalten
die Bedingungen unseres Lebens zu
diktieren und uns daran zu hindern die
Freiheit zu haben die uns garantiert
wurde in einer offenen Demokratie
wir sind alle Individuen wir haben die
Fähigkeit zu denken
zu entscheiden und vor allem gehört zu
werden
[Musik]
es ist vielleicht an der Zeit über
verschüttete Milch zu weinen
mist ich habe es verschüttet das ist
nicht gut
junge ich habe gerade die Bilder der
Schwangeren Kim Kardashian gesehen Mann
wie kann eine Frau wie sie warum wollen
sie das alle ansehen
sie ist ein Star
[Musik]
also
ihr wollt ihn nicht drin haben
okay geh da runter nein ich weiß nicht
wo man Gras her kriegt
das ist gelogen
ist eine unverfrorene Lüge nein ich
mache nur Witze
[Musik]